we got ding connection keeping it real
wheels how we keep it Andy Sachs
identity show 3ds apiece
we're trying to make the connection with
one of the world's most famous game show
holes on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but Chuck said if you don't know Islam
is evil and you don't know history and
you refuse to reason I'm not saying
every Muslim is evil different what do
you have to say about that Chuck I grew
up watching you my mother used to have a
television in the kitchen with a love
connection the first host of The Wheel
of Fortune was Chuck Chuck I was shocked
that someone in your position of
responsibility in the reach that you
have it would really just blanketly
labelled a community of 1.6 million
people right and then discredit our
history in a way that reflects your own
kind of sense of privilege right well
maybe you should engage us so I'd like
to invite you chuck just as you were
invited my family's Dan for years when
we watched you benefited from you I
would love to personally invite you to
contact myself and brother Edie's about
to sit down with you and perhaps try to
build and respond to some of the false
claims that you made which are very
irresponsible very irrational and a high
tide in times of Islamophobia Moscone
Muslims are under attack more than ever
before in America your words are
extremely important you may contribute
to a woman or a child or a family being
harmed Chuck and I know that's not what
you would want to see so why don't you
spin that wheel right and make that
connection we can build some love make
that connection cha we got number love
for you so reach out to us maybe we can
have you on the program
we'll see you chuck peace
[Applause]